do you think we'll eventually get to a
time where when you and I are alive
where we're gonna know what happened or
no
you mean with specifically John F
Kennedy yeah assassination do I think
well no I as far as the actual specifics
of what really happened I think it's too
much of a Cold Case okay uh I think we
can
I think intelligent people who know the
material can make a very kind of what we
call informed speculation of what really
happened I think that's becoming more
with the work that the ARB did
especially and which I mentioned before
about these documents on Vietnam and we
didn't get to talk about one of the most
Sensational discoveries these guys made
which was and I'm sure you're aware of
it operation Northwoods okay you want me
to explain that yeah go forward okay
operation Northwoods was a wild scheme
that was dreamed up by The Joint chisa
staff
in which they would create what they
call a causes belly a great event that
would provoke an invasion of Cuba some
of these were having uh you know uh
Cubans uh Cuban refugees go on a killing
spree in Miami all right uh another one
of them uh was to the most bizarre one
was to fly a drone
over Cuba
have a tape playing we're being under
attack and blow up the plane okay and
that would be the excuse to go in and
invade Cuba and Kennedy took a look at
these uh and he says uh no I I I don't
want to do anything like this all right
and this was brought to him by Edward
Lansdale and our Lyman lemnitzer okay
and then lemnitzer said well let's go
ahead and invade anyway
so and so Kennedy fired him all right
and unfortunately uh by hooker by crook
he ended up going to Europe and being
part of the whole NATO agreement anyway
so these are some of the things I
believe are very important in trying to
put together some kind of feasible
scenario Northwoods is really kind of a
scary kind of because if you want to
talk about false flag I mean it doesn't
get any more bigger than that of our
false flag
let me let me uh let me ask this
question from you when when say that
John F Kennedy Declassified documents
all of them are out and we have them are
we going to see anything is that going
to be like oh my gosh you know how come
you kept this from us from so many years
is there going to be anything
revolutionary and then the the second
part of the question would be the
following
how do we know they're going to release
everything anyways you know how are we
going to know that some of this stuff's
not going to be kept that never made it
out to us so two questions one will it
be that revolutionary two can they hold
back some documents that they don't want
us to see well I'm in agreement with uh
James here that I don't think that we're
really going to ever get a full clear
picture I mean we all want that I mean I
was a reasonable a lot we've been doing
the work we've been doing over the years
and pushing for release of Records
um I think it also uh ties to the fact
that you know when we started our work
we knew of a lot of CIA and FBI records
but what we didn't realize was all the
other types of records that were out
there that people brought to us or we
were able to to look and discover
did I answer the the second part okay
all right so so so I don't think that
I'm we're really gonna see I think we
need to keep pushing though we really
need to keep pushing do you think we're
going to see anything
uh I I really can't answer that question
with any kind of authority I think there
might be a couple of interesting nuggets
but if you ask me Patrick
with what they already did
well that was a big a huge what they
call a Quantum Leap already it's just
that except for people like you and you
know and there aren't that many of you
you know the MSM just doesn't want to
acknowledge a lot of this stuff and I
believe it's because of uh number one
they missed the boat on the
assassination on what really happened
and number two they completely missed a
boat on the cause and effect between
what happened to Kennedy and then what
happened later like for example the the
whole Vietnam War uh debacle you know so
they just don't want to deal with this
kind of thing and I and by the way
I believe that the MSM has gotten so bad
that kind of opened a door for people
like you okay because people want to
hear you know contrary to what they say
they want to hear this kind of stuff
it's so funny that you're we're showing
the the the numbers of the trust the
American people have in the US
government you know how much of that
matches the trust people have in the
mainstream media you're exactly right
the main the the lack of trust in the
government of mainstream media matches
so what does that say about the two
maybe they're on the same team yeah so
that's another part of the swamp this is
why we need people like Kennedy's we
need people like Reagan we need people
like Trump we need people who are
willing to push the envelope on both
sides of the aisle boy that that is a
really shocking yeah
wow
you're right you're right it's what is
it 21 do me a favor match it with the US
government match it with what you were
shown with the US government so if you
can put those two look at that that
right there the the lack of trust in the
Public's lack of trust in the U.S
government
matches its historic lows right now it
matches
Publix lack of trust go to the media in
a media so the media equals the
government so maybe they're just a uh uh
a spokesperson on behalf of the
government here you guys I want you to
say this to the people and they go and
tell us no wonder people don't trust the
media and the government today yes so it
it helps uh when guys in the media that
are not in the podcast side there's a
lot of them right now that are pushing
the envelope who are very interested in
this
um
Rogan's done a fantastic job
interviewing a bunch of a JFK
assassination he's done a phenomenal job
at it a few of us have put some time
into it as well but it's great on what
happens when you try to control the
people people eventually find a creative
way to get the message out to others and
then people say wow I'm starting to not
believe what you have to say I think you
guys are both full of [ __ ] mainstream
media and the government and I think
that's a good thing so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]